all right don't try to make too much out
of it just do your job
it is time for one of the great segments
we have ever come up i love it it is
called did his job
pretty simple in this game you know
life's pretty easy you either made it
happen or you did it shout out bill
belichick lead it off number one pine
sol nick fosa did he do his job pine sol
absolutely i think he did a wonderful
job he's facing one of the premier pass
rushers in the national football league
and i thought he was excellent he gave
up one sack a couple quarterback hits
but this young man to be able to deal
with bolsa and you know bosa his energy
he's coming after you every single play
absolutely outstanding i think detroit
found him a gym with this kid he is he's
gonna be pretty good he's big he's
strong he did a great job of competing
patriots feel like they found a gym in
mack jones they had a chance today it
looked like they may go get a win in the
first game of the season damien harris
though late fumble he did not do his job
and usually he's a reliable guy and i
hate to be him on monday because when
he's sitting in that meeting he's gonna
get cussed out by coach belichick and
i've actually seen coach belichick cut
some guys for fumbling the ball but this
kid he'll bounce back he's very mature
he's from the university of alabama and
i think he's going to bounce back i'm
not worried about him how does coach
belichick actually address fumbles you
do it in front of the whole group do you
do it personally he will cuss you out he
will cut you out in front of everybody
he doesn't care somehow that's a that's
about the answer
all right let's get to jordan milada
this is a big man getting out of space
and putting somebody on the ground
man first of all he got paid and i can
see why he got paid 64 million 40
million guaranteed he was absolutely
outstanding and when you see this big
man moves you see him moving watch this
watch him he's the left tackle get out
my way cameraman he's a left tackle and
watch him watch this hit
he's he's 10 yards down the field making
it
come on man look at this hit now you
wonder why oh
look at this guy big big physical guy
making a play like that that was
incredible that's a dv's worst nightmare
absolutely you just saw right there
let's get to another big guy taylor lawn
tough matchup he had with chandler jones
out there in arizona who did the job in
this match taylor lewand did not do his
job because he absolutely got
embarrassed by a pro bowl defensive end
chandler jones he should get paid he
should get both he should get tj watt
type money and i i just thought chandler
jones was outstanding today he played
with an edge and taylor lawn it's not
like he's a scrub he's a pro bowl left
tackle but i just i just see that energy
i see that look at him just getting to
the quarterback making plays
and taylor lewand he even tweeted out
right did he tweet something out about
getting used in the views yeah he did he
did he owned it he said he exposed him
he did own it we got it we got it but he
was coming off the injury too yeah
forget that torn acl in 2020. missed the
whole season he only played in five
games last year jamar chase he was
screwing up his job all pre-season long
great players know how to do their job
though when it matters from cincinnati
my friend right and you guys thought he
was a bus because he had so many drops
in the preseason
and i'm so proud of this young man he
bounced back and he showed a tremendous
amount of heart for him to be able to
bounce back in a real live game
situation and this is what they expect
from him big plays he's a talented kid
he just needs to keep his confidence
continue to believe in himself and
between joe burrow and him two former
teammates current teammates oh man i'm
excited about this young man he looks
springy out there on the autobahn
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports